across south africa's two most populous
provinces it was mob rule
for more than a week it started after
the jailing of former president
jacob zuma the government says the mob
was deliberately directed
towards distribution centers key
highways railways and ports
in haoteng and kwazulu natal you
couldn't do
something like that unless it was well
orchestrated
merida has been monitoring violence and
security in south africa for more than
30 years
how close did they come to effectively
destabilizing the state pretty close i
think
look it's
i mean really it's destabilization when
you get the economic damage we have and
the damage to race relations
basically it's because of the fact that
this province
is the key zuma support base
zuma's close family and friends deny
inciting the looting
across social media there are examples
of people using the imprisonment of the
former president
to justify the violence a slow police
response led to vigilante groups taking
the law into their own hands
here men from an indian majority
township in durban
are shooting at black men who've entered
from a neighbouring township
more than 200 people were killed 20 of
them in this area
including 29 year old percy chitauer his
nephew says his uncle was in a car when
he was shot
so kaiser just came then blocked the
road and
started shooting then the driver and my
uncle
the one who got shot like the driver did
not die
driving in those drill right now look at
this place it burn into the ground
the economy already battered by the
pandemic will contract
three percent according to one u.s
investment bank
president cyril ramaphosa admitted that
the government had been caught off guard
and was slow to respond to the violence
could this happen again
i think it could if the state doesn't
get its intelligence act together if it
doesn't
i mean what's disappointed me
is that some of the key instigators have
not been touched we know who they are
we've got to have to watch carefully
what the strategies there's a lot of
threats that they're going to continue
unless zuma is released government has a
list
of 12 people it suspects of instigating
the violence
only half a dozen have been arrested so
far how close
any of the people on the wanted list are
to jacob zuma is
unknown but how and if they are arrested
could be another test of authority for
the government of cyril ramaphosa
bernard smith al jazeera durbin